you went to the dinner with the Queen I
was with the Queen and the president
just last week yes for an American I
kept trying to figure out why why am I
here what how did this why did this not
did I win a ticket we were offered and
there's my white tie and Tails you're
very sure that is not a rental by the
way they had a powder-blue when I said
turned out it's a very surprisingly
informal they get it
you know everybody who works there just
kind of smiles and points you in the
direction and everybody says hello I'm
Julie I'm Simon hello nice to see you
well I run British intelligence how are
you everybody so kind of like on a
first-name basis did you meet her oh yes
yes indeed a chitty-chat or I talked
about doing Shakespeare when I was that
was how I got my start in the United
States doing Shakespeare and we compared
notes on that she did say this we'd love
to go to the theatre invitation of the
Queen
[Music]
it's just an edgy session she said we
loved going to the theater my sister my
sister could go to the theater to hear a
song once and then come home and I said
play it on the piano and she said yes
[Music]
majesty who used to call the Majesty
first and then you called ma'am
but now weirdly there's been a lot of it
because you've met the Queen Simon
haven't you I did I met her recently
yeah yeah yeah I met at the Narnia
premiere and she I thought I broke her
to be honest
the Queen has never had to worry about
the awkwardness of starting a
conversation she's never had an
embarrassing pause because she always
must speak first so she takes as much
time as she wants to do that so she came
up to me I was standing next to young
Joe McElderry the X Factor winner and
she said you're the musician to him well
someone whispered that he was in hurry
she went and I was just waiting for her
to speak and I swear it was like 30
seconds and my eye started to bead sweat
because I know you're still with us and
the brilliant one was Philip came by and
he because I played a mass in Narnia to
the voice of a mad and someone told him
what I was doing and he said when did
you realize you had the voice of a mouse
you think I was cast because I have a
naturally massy voice I have some sort
of disability that I made her cry I have
on good authority that at the end of
Narnia there's a very sweet moment with
Reepicheep the mass he he does this very
moving thing and the Queen was I swear
to God sitting maybe five seats down for
me wearing 3d glasses which is to see
the monarch in 3d glasses weren't even
gold on a stick they were just plastic
Polly style 3d glasses and and she she
dabbed her her eye with a tissue you
actually thought the Queen was gonna
have gold
[Music]
you haven't met the Queen but you did
you EULA Biss guitars performed for
Prince Philip and Camilla you shot one a
picture yes
what song did you choose to perform in
that's a good question
I think we performed I hate this part
no really wait no you hate Prince
Charles and Camilla and sang don't you
wish your girlfriend was call
[Applause]
laughing cowering songs
we're just giving
[Music]
you